thank you
it's a great honor to be here tonight at
Trinity Church part of the American
Empire project introducing these three
authors who have written books as part
of that and it's I think particularly
appropriate that this is taking place
just before tonight's well I've heard it
referred to in different ways the
so-called debate or the presidential
presentations bipartisan news conference
the rules are so strict that they will
not personally engage each other but
most importantly I think what is being
offered here tonight and where we are is
a sanctuary of dissent and dissent is
what makes democracy possible and that
is what we are going to hear tonight I
dare say the words that you will hear
words like blood and oil or crusade or
hegemony or survival will not be said in
those ways in tonight's presidential
discussion or in any of them which is
why it is so important also that we have
a media in this country that provides a
forum for the dissent that like trinity
church is a sanctuary for dissent
because I dare say at this point in this
country that that dissent is not just
that of a fringe minority or a silent
majority but the silenced majority
silenced by the corporate media so as
you listen to this discussion tonight I
hope you then go home and
all the networks call your newspapers
and ask where are these voices on the
national stage we begin tonight with
professor Noam Chomsky
it's very civilized be able to talk
sitting down I hope it's not a tribute
to my advanced age in the last week or
two a number of polls have been issued
from the leading polling agencies in the
world which have some quite interesting
results that bear rather directly on the
title for this evenings of presentations
the consequences of the new imperial
grand strategy as the bush program was
described by the main establishment
journal of foreign affairs shortly after
it was officially announced in September
2002 the national security strategy of
the most obvious effects of course are
the international ones which only were
released a few days ago turns out that
in the Muslim world almost everywhere
substantial majorities regard the United
States as a military threat to them
that's over seventy percent in Indonesia
Turkey Nigeria Pakistan other countries
in Europe majorities regard the United
States as a threat to world peace
Holland England France elsewhere they
report that distrust and dislike of the
United States has doubled or tripled in
many countries over the past over the
past year well that is consequences
people who feel threatened tend to react
and this sometimes they react violently
that
we already seen such reactions as
predicted was predicted in advance of
the invasion of Iraq that by independent
analyst by intelligence agencies a few
weeks ago we learned by the national
intelligence estimate of the United
States just before the war it was
predicted that it would increase the
threat of terror and in fact that's
happened another aspect of the new
imperial grand strategy which has been
less discussed but is far more serious
in its implications and has also had
extreme reactions is the what's called
the transformation of the American
military the rapid expansion of
offensive highly destructive military
capacity so a few weeks after the
national security strategy was announced
the Air Force Space Command announced
its plans for the next four years and
they intend to go from move from what
they call control of space for military
purposes Clinton's policy and violation
of the Outer Space Treaty they're going
to move from control of space to
ownership of space which which is
consistent with the national security
strategy no challenge tolerated anywhere
and they want to explain that means
instant engagement anywhere in the world
highly lethal destructive weapons from
space attacking unannounced anywhere in
the world world under close surveillance
if you continue to read these programs
they describe in detail how this
capacity can be developed and what it
will mean well maybe it isn't discussed
here but foreign intelligence agencies
read it they can find it on the same
websites or I did or where you can it's
not a secret and they react
as expected as predicted so in the Pats
it during the bush years according to us
estimates Russia has maybe tripled its
military spending it's displaying new
offensive military weapons
nuclear-tipped missiles more advanced
aimed at the United States they've
adopted the bush strategy of first
strike without effectively without
pretext the these are on hair-trigger
alert many of them this means being
controlled by automated systems we know
that our systems have many many errors
which require human intervention to
prevent a missile launch there's are far
less sophisticated deteriorating as the
Soviet economy deteriorates we're
essentially asking them to set the basis
for an accidental war which will happen
to destroy us all furthermore we're
compelling the Russians to transfer
missiles all over their territory huge
territory to counter us threats being
opposed at all their borders these are
taken in trains that any intelligent the
Chechen terrorists can intercept meaning
advanced nuclear missiles goin into the
worst imaginable hands China until
recently has kept from participating in
this for the one nuclear state that
doesn't have a much of an offensive
military capacity but that's changing
they've just announced that they're
tripling their offensive missile kapat
nuclear missile capacity and moving
towards a high-tech military with
offensive weapons very similar to I just
described within the next few years
this is not unnoticed by us strategic
analysts who predicted it's happening
just a couple of weeks ago two of the
leading US strategic analysts very
responsible respectable not given to
hyperbole wrote that the these policies
these transformation the military
policies and of course the expected
reactions to them may lead to what they
call ultimate doom and they go on to
express their hope that China will lead
a coalition of peace-loving countries to
counter us aggressiveness and militarism
we've come to a pretty pass when we read
that in mainstream journals other
recently released studies shed a good
deal of light on the state of American
democracy might be worth bearing in mind
if you can if you have a strong enough
stomach to watch what's happening later
the Chicago Council on Foreign Relations
publishes regular careful detailed
report of popular attitudes on
international affairs and they always
make interesting reading and the latest
one which just came out does
particularly so so here's a few examples
majorities of Americans often large
majorities I believe that the United
States should support the Kyoto
protocols the nuclear test ban and other
disarmament treaties majority believe
that the United States should join the
international criminal court even if
Americans are threatened with
prosecution they believe that the United
Nations not the United States should
take the lead in international crises
and that the US should accede to
majority wishes even if it opposes the
decisions in fact rather amazingly a
majority even are in favor of
eliminating the veto in the Security
Council the US
overwhelmingly is in the lead and
vetoing resolutions in the last 40 years
this has applications in Iraq other
polls have shown that a majority of the
population in the United States has
about the same stand as the Spanish
voters who last March voted for what was
called here withdrawing troops from Iraq
but it wasn't withdrawing troops unless
they were under UN supervision for a
long time about sixty or seventy percent
of the american population have felt
that the UN the US should take the lead
in iraq in security matters of economic
reconstruction political changes and so
on large majority believe that the
united states should join the World
Court the International Court of Justice
the Reagan administration pretty much
the people in office now withdrew the
jurisdiction withdrew both court
jurisdiction when it was about to
condemn the United States as it did for
an Internet what amounts to
international terrorism in its attack
against Nicaragua the majority believe
that the United in this case believe
that the US should rely on diplomatic
and economic rather than military means
in combating terror and quite strikingly
a large majority oppose preventive war
that's the US official doctrine held by
both candidates in gross violation of
international law and Nuremberg charter
large majority think that the United
States should keep within the UN Charter
limits that about twenty five percent
say the US should any state should
resort the force only if attacked
it's a narrow interpretation of the
Charter and over half say except this
slightly broader interpretation of the
Charter accepting the legitimacy of
pre-emptive war which means use of force
when you are an attack is imminent look
like a planes flying across the Atlantic
to bomb New York or something like that
so around seventy-five percent totally
opposed official policy of both parties
on a very crucial issue large majorities
believe that the United States should
increase spending on health education
and Social Security on specific issues
there are also stands are taken
radically different from the elite
bipartisan consensus so on Israel
Palestine seventy-five percent believe
the United States should be neutral
seventeen percent think it should tilt
toward Israel well all of these things
are interesting in themselves they also
tell us a lot about the state of
American democracy because these
positions are off the agenda they're not
in the electoral agenda the positions
are barely advocated in anywhere near
the mainstream which means that most of
the people who gave those responses have
never heard them they they're making
them up for themselves I probably think
they're the only people who hold them if
these issues were a topic of live debate
and discussion I don't think there's
much doubt that the numbers would be
much higher well that is one
illustration of a serious democratic
deficit the technical term for countries
that have formal democratic institutions
but then I'll function substantively the
polls on the election reveal the same
thing a couple of week two weeks ago the
Gallup polls asked people voters why
they're voting for
bush or kerry and at a set of choices
one of the choices was favor their
agenda ideas and platform goals for bush
that's six percent of bush's voters for
Kerry it's thirteen percent of Bush's
voters there were probably nobody's
paying is voting for them because of
their stand on anything and that's the
way elections are structured elections
are effectively run by the pr industry
which constructs extravaganzas and which
would show up come up every couple of
years and tries to focus laser-like
attention on them so that that's what
people will think of as politics
personalized extravaganzas
intermittently where you focus on
qualities as they call them is he a
strong leader would you like to meet in
or something like that not on their
sands not on issues they have to be kept
off the agenda and if you look at
people's attitudes on issues you can see
why it's not an irrational choice well
much of the world perceives this even if
we prefer not to and it adds to the
threat couple of words about a rack I
don't have to talk about the fact that
the pretext for the invasion have
successively eroded so their history but
as they collapse new ones come along
about a year ago the discussion fixed on
the new standard position that is the
u.s. invaded Iraq to fulfill what the
liberal press calls Bush's messianic
vision to bring democracy to Iraq Middle
East in the world so on the reaction in
the United States was intriguing there
was a near unanimous agreement that that
was the goal try to find an exception
there are critics plan critics the
critics say it's overreaching it's not
going to work noble inspiring but
they're means Iraqi culture is not
advanced enough to be able to accept
such dramatic steps or something like
that which be more realistic actually
there's one sector of opinion that
disagrees Iraqis just at the time that a
Bush's messianic vision was announced
with great fanfare in Washington other
Washington Post happened to publish a
poll of people in Baghdad who were asked
why they think the United States invaded
Iraq there were some who agreed with
near unanimous opinion here one percent
one percent said the goal was to
establish democracy most of the rest
said the obvious the u.s. invaded Iraq
to take control of Iraq's extraordinary
energy resources and to have a position
to reorganize the region and its
interest actually the result was a
little more nuanced a 50-percent said
the US wants democracy but will not
allow Iraqis to make their own choices
within it US would insist on influencing
it that's a sophisticated discouragement
on what imposition of democracy actually
means in the history of the West England
and the Middle East the United States
and its domains and so on well what is
the evidence for and against the view
that the u.s. invaded to fulfill wishes
messianic vision if the evidence for it
is very straightforward the president
said to try to find some other evidence
to support that conclusion well benign
statements of the nine intent by leaders
are totally meaningless they're
completely predictable they carried no
information no matter how grotesque the
monster is they make such statements so
we discard apparently not here it seems
that there's a hundred percent near a
hundred percent agreement even
among critics what's the evidence
against not going to run through it
because that would take another power
talk but it's just about anything you
look at I mean they're on history under
the British which also had pretensions
of independence and sovereignty the
history of us domains long-standing US
policy going back to the mid-1940s which
were to control the oil of the Middle
East because of what one historian of
the industry calls profits beyond the
dreams of avarice but more importantly
because it was what was called a
stupendous source of strategic power as
spagh Nia Brzezinski put it a few months
ago control of the resources of the
Middle East gives the United States a
critical leverage over the economies of
Europe and Asia those have been the main
competitors and rivals and I'll a
long-standing concern of US policy is
they might go in their own independent
and it still is have your control the
lever you get critical leverage with
George Kennan one's called veto power
well actually five minutes thought about
what the policies of a sovereign
independent Iraq would be suffices to
show that it would never be tolerated I
won't go into that but think about it
well all of this is off the agenda and
it's another illustration of a very
serious democratic deficit something
that should concern us well if this
conception is accurate in other words
the Iraqis aspire to the same vision
that's described here and Iraqis agree
that there is a cultural problem social
and cultural problem blocking it but
they think that problems here not there
and I think they have a reasonable
argument if that turns out if that is in
fact true
then that's actually a hopeful sign
because if this problem is here we can
do something about it a lot in fact
anything we're very free very privileged
plenty of opportunities we don't have to
pray that China will rescue the world
from us militarism and aggressiveness we
can take care of that right here but
that requires understanding what the
problems are perceiving the democratic
deficit and not being trapped into a
belief that democracy means pushing a
lever for somebody you like who's stand
you don't understand every couple of
years that's not democracy everyday work
to create basis for a functioning
democracy with plenty of opportunities
it is possible for them to compel the
government either one no matter who wins
because they have the same policies in
this regard to compel them to abandon
the major war aims in Iraq which Iraqis
understand even if we prefer not to and
that means dismantling going on to
dismantle the global policies which are
very deeply rooted in US history and
institutions it's a lot of work but
within reach and if that conception is
anywhere near accurate I think it is
there are faithful choices for us to
make faithful for Iraq for ourselves and
indeed far beyond
I think no I'm understood that I was
holding his watch so if you were
surprised for the first time that he
held within his time as a New York Times
Book Review said he is a global
phenomenon perhaps the most widely read
voice on foreign policy on the planet
Noam Chomsky's latest book he has
written more than a hundred is called
hegemony or survival America's quest for
global dominance and for those of you
who are not familiar with him professor
of linguistics and philosophy at the
massachusetts institute of technology we
now turn to James Carroll James Carroll
is the best-selling author of the
American book national book award
winning memoir and American Requiem
Constantine sword a history of Christian
anti-semitism he has written ten novels
and he lectures widely on Jewish
Christian Muslim relations his latest
book which he will join the other
authors and signing after this program
in the Trinity book shop is called
crusade chronicles of an unjust war
thank
well first I acknowledge it's a bit of a
dream to be introduced by Amy Goodman
thank you I'm among your Legion of
grateful fans and i also want to now as
the honor it is to be here you'll
understand first that i am edified to be
in a place where so many people
understand that there is something more
important than the Red Sox victory
tonight and of course seriously there
are two things more important one is
ending this abominable war in Iraq and
and the other is changing what made this
abominable war inevitable
and and you'll understand of course
having heard Noam Chomsky's succinct
summary of what this emergency were
faced with is and Michael Clara's
elaboration of whatever it is that gnome
and i will have added up to and his
contribution so I'm deeply honored to be
here and I just say personally I can't
help but acknowledge the space itself in
my life as a citizen of the city and a
person grateful for the magnificence of
this great church and its meaning for
this city and our country and speaking
quite personally more than 30 years ago
I was a young Catholic priest at a time
when Catholic priests weren't often in
the sanctuary of this church and I spoke
from that pulpit adding my timid voice
to the voices of so many who were
opposed to the war in Vietnam and if you
had told me if it had been somehow
possible for you to indicate to me that
I would be back here more than 30 years
later confronted with this war and this
drastic elaboration of the worst
impulses in our national life I would
have been even then as heartbroken
grease truck and angry as I am now a few
days after 911 President Bush
inadvertently accidentally used the word
crusade and I felt a kind of vertigo at
his use of that word not understanding
at the moment while understanding fully
the danger of it but being unable to
understand the absolute
pertinence of it since of course he
moved promptly to launch our nation on
nothing less than a crusade a perfect
match to jihad and if you had told me
all those years ago when I left religion
resuming my life imagining religion as a
private part of myself leaving what I
thought of as my public relationship to
religion if you told me all those years
ago that religion would resume its
character as a public problem in this
country I also would not have understood
and if you had told me that we would be
embarked upon a religious war in this
great pluralistic nation I wouldn't have
understood I'm proud to add my voice
tonight to the voices here and to add my
presence to your presence in manifesting
urgent concern about this emergency that
our nation has effectively presented to
the world having said all that I'm going
to put on the table my own considered
reaction to this crisis crusade this
book is a collection of the columns I
published in The Boston Globe assembled
as a book as part of the American Empire
project by tom engelhardt Sarah burst l
& K proofs of metropolitan books of hold
whom I acknowledge gratefully a column I
published on May 27 2003 bad weather
over America when will the bad weather
end why the distance between what is and
what ought to be
where r saddam hussein's weapons of mass
destruction if he was such a threat why
did his army perform so poorly does it
matter where he is if the war in Iraq
was not about oil why does the United
States insist on its indefinite control
if the war was instead about democracy
why are the Iraqi people including
Saddam's proven enemies excluded from
authority is Iraq to be like Afghanistan
where warlords rule and heroin thrives
are there more suicide bombers now than
ever how did relations between the
United States and its European allies
become so fragile will history recognize
the 21st century anglo-american combine
as a mere continuation of the British
Empire what do good intentions count for
if they leave a wake of wreckage and is
the bad weather the result of an
atmospheric low that will not lift
without the answers why are taxes being
cut when teachers and librarians are
being laid off what happened to the
campaign finance reform movement why is
the United States more divided by race
than ever when did its citizens ever
decide to forgo privacy how can low
income workers support their families
how much longer will the middle class be
able to afford health insurance why are
Americans eating so much bad food does
primetime television hold up a mirror to
our nation who teaches children to bring
guns to school what happens to teenagers
who fulfill every graduation requirement
except the test they can't pass how many
times will they fail that test because
their teachers were laid off
such impossible questions go a long way
toward explaining the American mood we
cannot answer them and so we do not ask
them and the emotional weather is lousy
thus the patently false false abelian
sub george w bush the doubtless man is
the perfect emblem of a nation so adrift
that it does not look twice at its real
condition whatever the technical reasons
for it the economy that refuses to
recover matches perfectly a broad
psychological stagnation why are
americans incapable of looking directly
at what we are doing and what we are
becoming abroad the united states wages
war on such vapp respects that when they
dissipate in the first breeze of
mourners wailing Americans take no
notice an old liberal dream of world
federalism is replaced by a program of
American world dominance at home and
anxious sadness under rights the civic
life careers feel terribly uncertain
leisure is a forgotten luxury in America
each boon now seems to carry a curse is
our freedom secured yes by a government
that can eavesdrop on every conversation
or we well-fed yes to the point of
obesity is our medical care superb yes
to the point of bankruptcy are we the
most heavily armed people in history
frightening ly so does the unprecedented
success of the national project over the
last generation bode well for the next
generation obviously not can we dare to
ask why an answer is apparent this very
day in Iraq the distance between what is
and what ought to be there is so vast
that only an act of communal self
blinding keeps Americans from seeing it
the dark national mood has many causes
but one cries out to be reckoned with
immediately the Iraqi war is a pack of
lies and Washington's war on terrorism
is a cynical manipulation of fear for
the sake of power so far the United
States have willfully participated in
this bush lead charade we have done so
out of the very insecurity that they
tell us not to fear as if the charade
however much it wrecks the world will
protect us but our underlying sadness
indicates what we need to know America
was not meant to be like this we are no
longer ourselves the bad weather will
not end until we face that cold truth
and change it
James Carroll one of the things that my
brother David Goodman and I have written
about in our book the exception to the
rulers is the original name the Pentagon
came up with for the invasion of Iraq
you probably have heard what it was
Operation Iraqi liberation but they had
to discard it because of the acronym oh
I L so they came up instead with
Operation Iraqi Freedom well today
return to our last speaker Michael Clare
who's taken on that issue with blood and
oil the dangers and consequences of
America's growing dependency on imported
petroleum Michael Clare is the five
college professor of program peace and
world Security Studies at Hampshire
College and immerse the defense
correspondent for the Nation magazine
and a contributing editor for current
history this is his latest book Michael
Clare
thank you I do have to say it's a thrill
of a lifetime a once-in-a-lifetime
experience to be on the podium with
people who I admire so much Amy Goodman
Noam Chomsky and James Carroll so I'm
just moved to be here with them and
makes me a little nervous but anyway
I'll do my best well you all know that
this evening is sponsored in part by the
American Empire project of henry holt &
metropolitan books and i think you all
know that there's an intense debate in
America about what the nature of our
foreign policy is in our overseas
behavior some analysts say that we have
constructed an empire an authentic
Empire like the British Empire and the
French Empire and the Roman Empire of
the past others argue that we've
constructed something different
something new or some form of
involuntary a voluntary system of
protectorates and subsidiaries I suspect
that will be debating the terminology of
empire for a long time to come even
among those analysts who contend that
the United States has forged in Empire
there's disagreement on its nature and
duration some say that the American
Empire is essentially benign aimed at
fighting tyranny in spreading democracy
around the world some say it is
essentially predatory designed to
exploit other countries for the benefit
of American elites moreover some
analysts contend that the new American
Empire will last for decades if not
centuries others say that it will be
short-lived that the experience of Iraq
will force a general disagreement
disengagement of American power I could
not possibly do justice to these
questions in the few minutes that I have
and I'm not sure that I have good
answers to them but this much I do know
insofar as Americans overseas
arrangements can be described as an
empire this is an empire of petroleum by
petroleum and for petroleum and it is
the pursuit and extraction of the rest
of the world's oil
that is driving America's outward
expansion and determining its future
course why do I say this before I can
answer that I have to make some
fundamental points about the role of
petroleum and its physical reality first
of all the American economy American
society and American power rests to a
greater degree than that of any other
nation on the availability of cheap and
abundant petroleum I don't have time to
go into this in detail you may want to
consult annual Europeans magisterial
study the prize but ever since the
discovery of oil and titusville
pennsylvania in 1859 and the formation
shortly thereafter of the Standard Oil
Company by john d rockefeller oil
extraction has been the most dynamic and
arguably the most important force in the
american economy the development of a
mammoth petroleum industry in this
country made possible the development of
the internal combustion engine and then
the automobile industry the highway
industry the petro chemical and plastics
industry to the tourist industry
airlines at modernised agribusiness and
most of all the suburbanization of
america it is not surprising then that
the ups and downs of the american
economy have been largely driven by the
availability and price of petroleum when
oil is abundant and cheap the economy
the economy thrives when it is scarce
and expensive as it is now the economy
cools and contracts every major
recession since World War two has been
precipitated by a rise in oil prices and
if prices continue to rise as they are
now we could well see a collapse of the
current economic recovery but this is
not all American military power rests
entirely on the foundation of oil the US
military more than that of any other
country is a mechanized military and
virtually every combat system in that
force every tank every Humvee every
plane every helicopter every missile and
virtually every ship is powered by
petroleum the United States could not
ploy its forces to distant parts of the
globe like Iraq and Afghanistan and keep
them there or rain down death on its
adversaries if it did not possess an
abundant and a reliable supply of oil
and American leaders going back to
Franklin Roosevelt have understood this
so petroleum is essential to the
American economy and because the united
states with was blessed with the
substantial supply of domestic oil and
was able to exploit this oil in an
efficient manner the american economy
has thrived over the past 100 years for
most of this time the United States was
the world's number-one oil producer the
Saudi Arabia of the first petroleum age
this oil bonanza I argue is the
principal reason for America's economic
dynamism over this long period but
America was not blessed with the world's
largest petroleum inheritance just the
first to be exploited on a very large
scale and petroleum is a finite resource
there's only so much in any given
reservoir and after a certain point you
use it all up this is as much true of a
single field as it is of a country's
entire underground supply the United
States was the first country to exploit
its oil resources on a large scale and
so not surprisingly it was the first to
face the depletion of those resources we
reached the point of maximum domestic
output in 1971 and have been
experiencing declining yields ever since
but having organized our entire economy
around the massive consumption of
petroleum we have been unwilling to
alter our consumption behavior although
we are no longer the world's number one
producer where it's number one consumer
and we continue to consume petroleum as
if we were the leading producer and so
since 1971 to satisfy our oil habit
we've had to acquire more and more oil
from abroad we have preached the fifty
percent point of dependence on foreign
supplies in 1998 it's now fifty-five
percent it'll reach sixty percent by the
end of this decade
and then sixty-five to seventy percent
in 2020 and there's no amount of oil in
Anwar that will change that trend one
bit the other fundamental point to make
about oil is that there is a historic
shift underway and the locus of world
oil production initially as you would
expect oil production was centered in
the industrialized countries or their
close neighbors in 1950 fully two-thirds
of the world's oil was produced in the
United States Canada Mexico Europe and
the Soviet Union including Baku and
Grozny then the Houston of the soviet
oil system but these fields were the
first to be developed and I've said that
made them the first to face depletion so
by 1999 only two fifths of the world's
oil came from these countries and by
2025 their share will drop to one-third
meanwhile we've seen a dramatic
long-term shift in the center of gravity
of world oil production to the
developing world especially the Middle
East Africa and the Andean region of
Latin America these countries accounted
for only one-third of world oil supplies
in 1950 but will account for two-thirds
in 20-25 I know that some of you are
familiar with the phenomenon of peak
petroleum or the gradual depletion of
the world's oil this is an important
phenomenon but from a geopolitical
perspective it is the shift in the locus
of oil output that really matters to us
from the global north to the global
south the more we look into the future
whatever the day-to-day level of oil the
greater the amount of it that will be
coming from the developing world and
often from unstable or deeply unfriendly
countries these countries have all been
subjected to colonial domination in the
past Nigeria Angola Colombia Venezuela
Iran Iraq Saudi Arabia Kuwait
Afghanistan and Kazakhstan and for the
most part their public's Harbor deep
deep resentment towards any any
expression of colonialism
and oil the pursuit of oil by American
companies is seen by them as the modern
incarnation of the Imperial empires so
it is the intersection of these two
factors America's growing dependence on
imported petroleum in the growing shift
in world oil output to unstable areas of
the developing world that provides the
impetus the engine of American imperial
expansion ironically the first American
leader to recognize this fundamental
reality and give it concrete form was
that great defender of democracy
Franklin Delano Roosevelt it makes me
very sad to say this because I admired
Roosevelt and think he did many
wonderful things but I've distressed to
learn of his role in this there's no
doubt that he's the one who laid the
foundation for the modern American
Empire recognizing that the United
States would become reliant on imported
petroleum and concluding that the most
important new source of oil would be the
Middle East Roosevelt decided to
establish a protectorate over the most
important new supplier the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia now bear in mind that at
1943 the United States didn't even have
diplomatic relations with the kingdom
but when US geologists told FDR that the
kingdom possessed the world's largest
supply of untapped petroleum he
determined to place that oil under
American dominion and so in February
1945 his world war two was drawing to a
close he traveled to the Middle East and
met with King Abdulaziz urban saloon the
founder of the modern saudi dynasty you
have to imagine the scene the president
of the united states in the acknowledged
leader of the free world sitting next to
a medieval potentate accompanied by
astrologers and slaves together the two
leaders agree that the United States
would form a protectorate over the
kingdom of saudi arabia promising to
defend the king and his male heirs in
perpetuity in return for privileged
access to saudi arabian oil this
arrangement form the cornerstone of us
imperial power in the Persian Gulf and
can
10 used to govern US policy in the
region to protect the royal family in
Saudi oil fields the United States and
military advisers to the kingdom
established military bases there to play
it deployed a naval fleet and provided
with the most sophisticated weapons I
obviously don't have time to recount
this history but protection of Saudi
Arabia and the neighboring oil shikdum
switch also became American
protectorates was the essential impetus
for the Truman Doctrine the Eisenhower
doctrine the Nixon Doctrine and most
importantly the Carter doctrine of 1980
which states that oil from the Persian
Gulf is a vital interest of the United
States and that in protecting this oil
the United States will use any means
necessary including military force it
was a Carter doctrine that provided the
rationale for the first Persian Gulf War
of 1992 91 and i believe historians will
conclude it was the ultimate inspiration
for the second Persian Gulf War the 2003
invasion of Iraq and it was the
deployment of large numbers of American
troops in Saudi Arabia to enforce the
Carter doctrine that turned Osama bin
Laden from an instrument of us
penetration in the region into an
adversary of us penetration from a
historic perspective 911 must be seen as
a conscious effort by bin Laden to
forcibly dissolve the u.s. protected
protectorate of a Saudi Arabia
established by FDR and King Abdulaziz in
1945 so long before President Bush jr.
came to office the United States had
established an oil-based Empire in the
Persian Gulf and fought a series of
overt and covert was to protect it what
this president bush has done what is his
distinctive mark is to globalize the
American oil Empire by extending the
Carter doctrine to other keep producing
areas in the developing world the first
thing that Bush did when he came to
office was to appoint an energy
commission headed by Vice President Dick
Cheney to study America's energy
requirements
I think you know that this commission
met in secrecy and relied on advice from
Enron ExxonMobil and other giant
companies what is less understood is
that they decided to perpetuate
America's oil based energy system for
another 20 years and to do so to
increase rather than diminish American
reliance on imported petroleum and this
could lead to only one conclusion the
United States must gain access to
foreign oil no matter where it is
located no matter how remote or
unfriendly the country where the oil is
located the Persian Gulf is not enough
to satisfy our ever-growing appetite the
United States must also extract the oil
of Africa Asia Latin America and the
former Soviet Union more and more of it
all the time there is no other way they
concluded to maintain the American oil
driven economic system as we know it and
because this relentless drive to exploit
the rest of the world's oil is certain
to invite opposition whether from
revolutionary guerrillas in Colombia
nationalistic populace in Venezuela
Islamic fundamentalists in Central Asia
or ethnic separatists in Nigeria the
Bush administration set out to establish
US military domination over all of these
other oil-producing areas this has led
to the commitment of American troops and
advisors to pipeline and refinery
protection in Iraq Colombia the Republic
of Georgia to the establishment of new
bases in the Caspian Sea and the search
for new bases in Africa slowly but
surely the United States military is
being converted into a global oil
protection service and so I return to my
original point the new American Empire
if that's what it is is an empire of
petroleum by petroleum and for petroleum
it is of petroleum because it is based
on the establishment of protectorates
over key oil-producing nations in the
developing world it is by petroleum
because it relies on a global military
force that is almost entirely powered by
petroleum and it's for petroleum because
its main purpose is to extract enough of
the world's oil to perpetuate a
petroleum intensive economy and way of
life in the United States where does
this leave us if my analysis is correct
the war in Iraq it's not the first
American war over petroleum nor will it
be the last because America's need for
petroleum is growing and because we have
chosen to militarize our foreign policy
there will be more wars for oil is it
worth it that's for you and the American
people to decide personally I do not
believe that we should sacrifice the
life of a single American soldier
without of any other country to provide
the United States with an abundant
supply of petroleum I believe that we
must demilitarize our foreign energy
policy and repudiate our blood for oil
Protectorate over Saudi Arabia this will
require a greater commitment to energy
conservation at home and a rapid
development of petroleum alternatives
such as wind solar and hydrogen this
will be arduous and expensive I know but
is the only ethical and the only
patriotic costs that we can follow I
hope that you'll agree with me thank
oh thank you
Michael Claire
if a few people very quickly want to
come up to the microphone to ask a
question and you'll have to make those
brief I just wanted to observe that both
the president and vice president have
said that they would do again what they
did and that was invade Iraq that they
think they did the right thing and
that's the Republican ticket for 2004
what might have surprised many is that
John Kerry said something similar when
he was asked at his campaign stop of the
Grand Canyon if he knew now if he knew
then what he knew now would he vote the
same way which was he voted for the
invasion he said yes I think that
shocked a lot of people but his tune did
seem to change right around the time of
the convention maybe that's because on
Sunday the day before the Republican
National Convention the largest protest
mass protest in the history of US
political conventions took place outside
Madison Square Garden a half a million
people
as people line up I was wondering if
either of all of you would like to
respond very quickly to a most obvious
question which is do you see a
distinction when it comes to the issue
of American Empire and this invasion and
occupation between the two major party
candidates john kerry and george bush
and what they would do Noam Chomsky in
the case of Iraq I think their positions
are very difficult to distinguish they
might have done they might have
initiated different policies but given
what's there now they doesn't seem to be
much difference both seem committed to
the war aim that I think Iraqis properly
understand gaining control of Iraqi oil
which is indeed unique in the world it's
the last known huge basically untapped
even unexplored source of very cheap and
easily accessible oil so you control
that and establish a base in a hope of
the plant dependent client state with
military bases for gaining control over
the region both for the reasons that
Mike eloquently described and also for
the reasons that this big knee of
Brzezinski my greatest hero described I
think accurately it does grant the u.s.
critical leverage over others and that's
been a long-standing problem they're our
rivals they might go in an independent
courts on empire generally I think there
are some differences I assume that Kerry
would follow roughly the Clinton
policies something these are not
elections between individuals but being
groups of advisers and constituencies
and his
roughly Clinton's so in the case of for
example military militarization of space
and other aspects of the massive
expansion of offensive and destructive
military capacity the Clinton position
was more nuanced similar position but
there is a difference between control of
space and ownership of space for
military purposes and everything that
flows from it there are major
differences i think domestically
separate issue the Bush administration
would like Americans to think there's no
particular difference between John Kerry
and George W Bush on the war in Iraq
John Kerry stands in the middle ground
on this war he doesn't stand where I
stand I'm not running for president I
wouldn't get like the dog kept her in
this country I'm grateful that John
Kerry is addressing most of his
political thrust to people who are
undecided in this election but I also
think it's crucial to listen to the
whole man his whole life story and the
mantra of what he says which i believe
is is a credible position and one that
needs to be really affirmed in this
political season going forward he would
only go to war when it's necessary and
the bottom line is that the deception
about this war was its necessity there
was no necessity for this war and that's
a theme to which carry has been
considered on which he's been consistent
into which he returns again and again
there's a there is a world of difference
between john kerry and george w bush on
the question of the war in iraq and on
that difference this election stands
in the interest of discussion i'll pass
because i share Jim's feeling a few
months ago when you are asked in milton
massachusetts about how we get
progressive radio programs on such as
democracy now into the boston area you
talked about the tight grip that the
boston radio stations have over their
content today the executive director of
WBUR stepped down amidst a lot of
controversy about patronage etc in this
window of opportunity is there anything
we can do to help get a me on locally in
larger stations than Boston College's I
think there's quite a lot that we can do
walking in here today somebody told me
that they can watch democracy now on
Cambridge cable television that could be
done on every every town in the region
everywhere in fact there's plenty of
options there they're not exploited as
fillets they should be and the same I
don't know about wbur but the same can
be done on many radio stations let me
think I don't know that person but very
good point I democracy now is
broadcasting in Boston on Cambridge
community television and Cambridge
Boston neighborhood network on wzb see
Boston College every day and it also
broadcasts on both satellite networks
Dish Network every day channel 9 4 15
which is free speech TV and on direct TV
channel 375 which is linked TV we also
video an audio stream at
democracynow.org where millions of
people access the program around the
globe and are broadcasting on more than
275 radio and television stations NPR
stations where we beat all things
considered in morning edition hands down
in fundraising so maybe be you are or
bgh would be interested gbh would be in
interested on public access TV anyone
can get us on their public access TV
station increasingly on PBS stations so
you can just call your stations these
are public radio and television you are
the public in order for dissent to be
effective it's helpful if the dissenter
gets heard and also it's helpful if he
or she doesn't get crushed after he or
she speaks out that's why it's so
important to have steam professors like
yourself at places like MIT or Columbia
or representing the left who have the
ability to get heard and also can't so
easily be crushed but who are your
successors who are your successor are
you asking me
I mean you know there are vibrant lively
popular movements all over the country
there are many more of them there ever
been in the past at least in my lifetime
they're disorganized we're a
disorganized disunited atomized country
but they're all over the place and out
of them come speakers their speakers
don't come from know where they come
from popular movements that exist I mean
for example I was talking on the Vietnam
War in churches 40 years ago but there
were maybe four people in the audience
you know the minister the organizer
somebody who wandered in because he was
hungry or something and another person
would be have been happy to kill me and
this went on until popular movements
developed they've expanded developed
undertaken all sorts of actions on every
imaginable issue sometimes quite
effectively it's changed the country and
it's created the opportunity in which
you know and i gome tonight at all it's
like every other night to spend half an
hour turning down invitations not
because i don't want to take them but
because i can't and there's plenty of
opportunity for others to do the same
and many are I mean just compare the war
in Iraq with the war in Vietnam I mean
the war in Iraq happens to be the first
time in the history of the West Europe
and the United States in which there was
massive public protest against war
before it was officially launched the
case of the war in Vietnam which was far
more destructive and violent and brutal
a far more criminal act it took years
before there was any protest at all
literally on by the time
was visible South Vietnam it and
practically wiped out and even then the
protest was mostly against a peripheral
part the bombing of the north that's a
huge change in consciousness over 40
years and that's where activists
organizers come from where the
opportunities for speakers to contribute
what they can come from so the
groundwork is there all that's needed is
to use the opportunities you can be a
speaker for example but comment and then
a question for professor Chomsky I just
want to thank all the panelists
wholeheartedly for your healing and
enlightening words this evening thank
you very much and for amy goodman i
watch your show every day Monday through
Friday and thank you for helping to
somewhat in my ignorance and especially
the coverage on Haiti was really
incredible and on Reagan as well and my
question dr. Chomsky is I heard that
there was a letter although I didn't see
it but there was a letter written to
Ralph Nader asking him to drop out of
the presidential race at this letter had
numerous signatures on it from prominent
individuals yourself being one so I
heard please correct me if I'm if I'm
wrong am i incorrect about that one
completely in here ok I'm very sorry
well so then let me just ask this
question which is Ralph Nader was
interviewed on Democracy Now the other
day and I think it was kind of a
poignant interview where he stated that
he felt that many prominent individuals
on the left that had supported him
before now did not support him and he
felt that a lot on the Left had lost
their nerve so i just opened the
question to all the panelists then do
you how do you agree with that and how
do you feel about how well I can't speak
for others but my position on this
election is exactly the same as it was
in two thousand namely that the election
it's given the huge
democratic deficit in the United States
and the fact that elections are have
become a marginal issue in my opinion
where issues are shunted to the side
insofar as they exist and the massive
focus is on personality personalized
extravaganzas given that fact the most
important thing reaction to an election
is to not pay too much attention to it
and go on with the important work of
building popular organizations
increasing activism reconstructing a
democratic culture in which elections
will be as meaningful as say they are in
the second largest country in this
hemisphere Brazil however elections
exist can't ignore them takes a little
spend a little time thinking about what
you do in my opinion it takes should
take about five minutes to figure out
what to do in this one and my opinion
was the same in the year 2000 as it is
now in a swing state where the vote may
matter I think you should vote to keep
out the more dangerous and they are
dangerous of the two can't of not
candidates but groups personalization is
something we should ignore these are
just two different groups two different
constituencies and so on they're
different and the one around bush i
think is very dangerous so where your
vote matters i feel as i did in the year
two thousand one should vote to keep
them out in a safe state where your vote
doesn't affect things you got a lot of
choices i mean if you're interested in
say party building for the long term you
would cast the vote for those who are
day after day year after year working on
party good party building if your
interest is something else that I vote
for that if you think a way to protest
the to express your opposition to the
personalized the quadrennial
extravaganzas is to abstain do that I
think that was the same position in the
year 2000 i think it is now i don't
think we should spend a lot of time
thinking
are talking about it if they're much
more important things to do I feel a
rare note of disagreement with noam
chomsky and I just want to register it I
think is a huge difference between the
Democratic Party in the Republican Party
in this country now the Republican Party
is becoming a dangerous party in the
United States at every level and it
should be opposed at every level and
every opportunity there is to vote
against it should be taken it always
matters it always matters in
Massachusetts everywhere it always
matters on the whole range of issues
personal freedom questions of sexual
ethics of it even if we chose already
determined absolutely a safe state is
say well dated well we're by definition
this is this is a safe state only in
relationship to the presidential
election right and on other issues
that's a it's a matter of party building
as a matter of public affirmation and
it's a matter of on a really really
understanding that there is a major
conflict in this country right now that
must be engaged at every level and and
the Democratic Party which is far from
perfect simply must be supported
wherever it's positive for Republican
candidate happens to be more progressive
one I mean in the past i voted for
republic well if you give me an example
on that one we could have we could
discuss for example during the 1960's
the most outspoken opponents of the
vietnam war at the Congressional level
happen to be Massachusetts Republicans
and I voted for them it's certainly true
that at the local regional sometimes
state level you should do whatever is
important to do this the issue that was
raised the safe state swing state issues
solely has to do with presidential
election solely with that
Michael Clare because this is such an
important topic and also bear in mind
that some people are voting for the
first time ever and there's been a huge
increase in registration by young people
and marginalized voters for whom this is
an existential act and in a more
important existential act even though I
understand gnomes analysis I think I
think it's it's such an important necked
and i agree with James Carroll that
these people are dangerous and just just
think where we are now compared to me
where we were four years ago imagine
where we'll be four years from now if
the Republicans are still in power I
shudder to think where our freedoms will
be then and so even voting in a swing
state against the Republicans I think is
crucial a safe state a safe state I'm
sorry even in a safe state as an
existential act of expression of
opposition for those for whom it is
their first vote and for others I think
it's crucial
let's take one more question aiming
hoodman first I just wanted I just
wanted to thank you for talk that you
gave at Evergreen State College in 2003
it's what brought me here and to
listening to these people and to you
every day but professor Chomsky the
other day on the vice presidential
debate Dick Cheney related his
experience as an election monitor in el
salvador in 1983 and I was just curious
at the time and screamed out to me that
I wanted to have your context of what
was happening in 1983 when Dick Cheney
was an election monitor there seemed to
bring almost a tear to his eye in 1983
the US was engaged in major wars
throughout Central America in some cases
the u.s. controlled the government and
therefore was able to rely on state
security forces to crush and destroy
efforts at Independence and democracy
like was fighting a major war against
the church el salvador at that time
there was a what's sometimes called a
demonstration election an election held
under conditions of extreme terror and
violence and yeah Cheney I didn't know
he observed that he could have it was a
pretty meaningless election there was
actually a much more important election
in 1984 in Nicaragua which was a country
that was under military attack but where
the state security forces were not the
terrorist force it was being supported
by actually bipartisan support in the
United States in various ways to try to
crush the independent government
nevertheless they had a an election
which was monitored very heavily it was
the most heavily monitored election I
think in history of may be anywhere
certainly Latin America Latin American
Studies Association very hostile Dutch
the official delegation the British
parliamentary human rights delegation
and so on and they judged a pretty fair
election by Latin American standards
here it was wiped out of discussion
across across the spectrum because it
came out the wrong way so almost
universally what is said here is the
first election was nineteen ninety is
that one came out the right way under a
gun I shouldn't say 1984 election was
free by regional standard certainly came
out the wrong way didn't take place
that's the kind of thing we should be
concerned about and that's bipartisan
unfortunately for fear of being accused
of flip-flopping we will allow in one
last question and then the authors our
speakers will be going into the bookshop
and or staying here and books are going
to be sold in the bookshop and I really
do want to encourage people to buy these
books I want to just stress and talking
about the politics of publishing what an
enormous difference it makes when books
like these make it when people in this
country start to read these different
points of view there is a proliferation
of conservative imprints of publishers
and when they learn that there is will
they call it markets but communities of
people which I would say represent the
majority of people in this country that
are interested in books like blood and
oil like crusade chronicles of an unjust
war and hegemony or survival America's
quest for global dominance that when
those books succeed for every one of
those books it makes room for another
book and it is extremely important
message to be sent and it also sends a
message to the corporate media in this
country that there are other experts out
there outside of that small circle of
pundits who knows so little
about so much last question I were to
start first first of all thank you for
the panel but I want to since we talked
about the I gonna home just be right
address oh okay we talked about the
Empire making I want to know how Sudan
and question of Darfur fits in because
we are right now alcohol and power said
that there is genocide in darfur yet we
just ignore genocide in Palestine second
in we talking about Empire first of all
I disagree with mr. Carroll that there
is a lot of difference between John
Kerry and bush as we know what they are
doing a lot of people including in elite
disagree and the about the invasion of
Iraq and the thing actually is not in
the interest of empire that's
interesting then i can mention many
names the reason is because they believe
really this does not serve the interest
of empire rather it served the interest
of Israel and one thing that you talk so
much about the foreign policy what I'm
saying that is not interest of the
Empire I'm talking about from foreign
policy point of view not about other
issues education or other things and you
just totally ignored a Justice somehow
push aside the question of Israel many
people talking about Israel is asian of
the foreign policy and the question of
dale con because even Jennifer Matthew
last night mentioned from Carnegie Hall
endowment that Bush did not go into
world with free will he was where she
was mentioning the rule of no con about
that
otherwise why for example not only in
the Middle East we are looking for oil
but also in Africa they have the oil of
child for eleven percent tomorrow
probably chat young people are going to
pick up you know the gun and fight and
dentists the question is I want to know
what is the role of Israel in there you
know culture the Empire and Middle East
right now dot pushing for inversion of
in other countries because that's not
looking to eliminate their energy to do
that let us how that all you know to the
States thank you the question of Israel
well I'm glad to have the chance to
address this the implication of your
question because I didn't hear a full
clear statement but I would like to just
suggest that we should be very careful
of blaming the problem of the war in
Iraq on Israel this is not Israel's
problem this is America's problem and
there is a movement there is an impulse
there is a kind of instinctive reaction
that looks to blame Israel and it's
wrong having said that the struggle
between the Israelis and the
Palestinians is crucial and is clearly
involved in this centrally and my own
position is that the United States of
America has failed that struggle the
Bush administration by not pressing the
Sharan government to be what more less
reliant on overwhelming force less
reliant on the dead or alive impulse
that comes from Washington also the
United States of America has to
absolutely recommit to the peace process
the possibility of the realization of
the ambitions of both peoples and it is
simply not inconsistent with full and
complete support for the call for
justice for the Palestinian people to
also affirm the clear and absolute right
for the security of the people of Israel
on that note want to thank you very much
for coming out encourage you to tune
into democracy now we will be
broadcasting tonight's forum encourage
you to go over to the book shop to pick
up these books and to tell your friends
about them give them as gifts send them
to politicians to friend and foe and we
are also passing around a daily digest
email signup list if you want to get the
daily headlines from Democracy Now or
you can go to our website at
democracynow.org and you'll get those
media alerts and headlines thank you
very much and thank you for listening to
a conversation about American Empire